Now the Arab League is
officially welcoming
a longtime international pariah
back into the fold.
It has re-admitted Syria
as a full member,
despite the government's
alleged war crimes
and an ongoing civil war.
It's not a basher, reports
President Bashar al-Assad himself
could return to the spotlight
on the regional stage
as early as next week.
An unthinkable prospect now
a reality
the Arab League has reinstated Syria
more than a decade
after Damascus was suspended over
President Bashar
al-Assad's
deadly crackdown
on anti-government protests.
Now two of an Arab led political process
to end the bloody Syrian civil war
that has haunted the region for years.
What we're talking
now is a political process
in which the Arabs
will have a leading role
in efforts
to try and bring about a solution to the
to the crisis.
And in order for us to succeed,
we will all need to work together.
Syria says it welcomed the announcement
and that it would participate
in strengthening joint Arab actions.
The decision
to welcome Syria back into the fold
hasn't come as a total surprise.
Following a series
of diplomatic victories for Assad
last week,
Iran's president, Ibrahim Razi,
met with Assad in Damascus, a first
for an Iranian head of state in 13 years.
And in April,
a similar visit
to the Syrian capital
by Saudi Arabia's foreign minister.
But not all Arab states are supporting
Syria's return,
including some
that have actively supported Syria's
rebel groups.
Qatar,
the minister of foreign affairs,
measured.
But Mohamad al-Ansari
said his country continues
to stand against
the normalization of ties
with the Assad regime
and among those most wary of Syria's
a century.
Israel,
the IDF, suspected of hitting targets
inside Syria
to prevent Iran from gaining a foothold
as part of their proxy war.
And for the
millions of
Syrian refugees
brutalized by Assad's war,
it may be hard to accept this decision
as anything but a betrayal
and a must have had them inhuman.
And this means nothing to us
because we are displaced
and forced to leave our towns.
They are just like him.
This is why they took him back.
They are all useless
Instead of Arab leaders
helping us
and getting us out of those camps
where we suffer and live in pain,
they whitewash the criminal
and killers hands from our blood.
President Assad could now participate
in the upcoming Arab League
summit in Saudi
Arabia,
though the league's secretary
general has been clear
this does not mean an end
to the Syrian crisis.
With that,
I would add Syria in a shuttle market.
The return of Syria
is the beginning of a movement
not an end.
The direction of the resolution
to this crisis in Syria
will take time for procedures
to be implemented, and it will be gradual
shifting politics,
changing the landscape
of the Middle East,
but caught in the middle.
Syrian refugees and citizens
still facing an uncertain future
with no clear indication of how or when
President Assad will be held to account.
Now the Bashir, CNN London
the US is criticizing
the Arab League's decision,
but some say the Biden administration
deserves criticism itself
for not doing enough
to stop the warming of ties
with Bashar al-Assad.
Our next guest signed an open
letter back in March
urging stronger
leadership on the Syrian issue.
Ambassador James Jeffrey
served as US
Special Representative
for Syria engagement from 2018 to 2020.
Ambassador, thank you
for joining us this evening.
Thank you for having me on.
So many will find this
an absolute betrayal of the Syrian people
and of course, the half a million or
so who've died as a result of this brutal
civil war.
But as Nadia was saying in her report,
there is not exactly coming
as a surprise.
Can you first explain to us, Ambassador,
as to the regional calculus
going on here
and why this is happening now?
First of all, this is both less
I would emphasize your report about what
the Arab League
president said
and also the other reports.
This is a beginning of a process.
It's very slow.
So this is about less
than what it looks like
But in another sense, it's more
since the late Obama administration
with John Kerry
through the Trump administration,
the U.S.
conducted negotiations
with Russia to achieve
exactly what the Arab League is
now trying to do directly with Assad.
That is to resolve
all of these problems that were covered
so well in your report.
The Iranian dangerous presence
that Israel is striking,
the various terrorist
groups
awash in Syria,
that we have troops there fighting.
The problem with refugees
the accountability of the regime,
the half a million people killed.
These things are not going to be fixed
by Assad being in the Arab League.
They're not going to lift the U.S.
and European sanctions
they're not going to get Turkish and U.S.
troops out or Israeli
airplanes out of airspace.
That requires Assad to make compromises.
We have made that clear.
Tony Blinken,
the secretary of state, called
the Jordanian foreign minister Safadi
on Thursday.
Safadi is the leader of this effort
to make it clear this how has to be done.
Step by step, in accordance with the U.N.
resolution that covers
all of these problems.
So we have to wait and see.
This is not a revolutionary change.
It does show, however,
that the Arab states
are impatient with the U.S.
role at present in the region,
and that's troubling.
Yeah.
So you are saying
that this has been on the table
really for some time with US involvement
Why then what prompted your letter,
your open letter to Joe Biden in March
effectively saying that words
were not enough?
What other action
were you pushing for that?
Well, we were all aware
of the Arab effort.
Actually, King Abdullah announced it.
Jordan announced it
a year and a half ago,
and he delivered a version of it
to President Putin in Moscow.
So this has been underway for some time.
We're concerned
not that the Arabs
have the wrong approach,
but the ability to carry it out.
Assad is a past master at deception.
He has shown he will not compromise.
Our fear
is that if a committee of Arab leaders
competing among themselves,
as they typically do
on these things, tries
to get Assad to comply, it won't work.
And what's at stake
here is not just the refugees
for which we and others are providing
many billions of dollars a year.
Are the terrorist groups or the fighting
that's still going on in Syria
This is a geopolitical issue.
It involves a possible
big win for Iran and Syria
and the region.
The Arabs don't want that.
They want to get a run out
and they want to get the region
in, particularly Syria, calm.
I'm just not sure they are the best
agent to do that.
Letter was United States.
You play a bigger role
instead We're apparently going
to let the Arabs go ahead with this.
This may or may not work.
So what are the
what are the downsides here?
What are the pitfalls of this being led
now by an Arab coalition?
And do the United States
have any foothold
still to enter in at this late stage
and influence proceedings?
Oh, sure.
Because you see that
the things Assad wants,
the Arab League and Arab states
cannot get it.
I would be very surprised if the Emiratis
or the Saudis or others
are going to open their checkbooks
and try to pay for the $400 billion
of destruction, mainly wrought
by the Russians
and the Iranians
on behalf of Assad inside Syria.
There are strong U.S.
and European sanctions.
As I said, there are Turkish
American and Israeli military forces
operating in Syria.
There is a third of the country
that's under the control
still of one or another
form of opposition groups.
None of those things can be fixed
by the Arab League.
Without these things
being fixed and above all,
without a success to the U.N.
process.
22 54 is a resolution.
Assad isn't going to get very much,
and it's up to him
to start helping to fix these things.
If he does,
then this Arab League
initiative might have some progress
Mean, the reality
is, though, Ambassador,
that this is now something
that's in motion. How important is it
for those Arab allies to
try to exact a price from Assad
in exchange for reintegration here?
Do you think that is happening?
And what should that exchange be?
You've put your finger on the problem.
Any diplomatic
you don't get any resolution
to any international problem
without a diplomatic process.
But any diplomatic process
tends to take on a life of its own.
And the various participants
want to save that process in the process
rather than the results
you want to get on the ground,
become the focus.
That's what I'm afraid of.
What we told the Russians and they told
the Syrian government,
even though they didn't
accept it, was, look,
we want to do a step by step resolution.
Essentially, the plan
that the Arabs are now
putting on the table.
But if not, we'll be happy
to freeze this conflict
and continue on with our sanctions
and continue on
with our military presence,
as we believe the Turks
and the Israelis
will also do until you actually comply,
because we saw this
as a geostrategic problem.
I'm not sure the Arabs will be that tough
if they yield,
if they start taking paper promises and
insignificant
concessions on Assad spots as enough,
they'll simply put pressure on us,
the Europeans, the Turks and the Israelis
to start making our own concessions.
That's riskier.
So important.
Ambassador, here,
this context in light of
what is emerging here.
Thank you so much for coming
on, giving us your insight on this.
We appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
Now we're just learning
about an alleged
smuggling operation by Iran
to get weapons into Syria.
This according to an Israeli
defense official
and two sources familiar with U.S.
intelligence.
They say Iran used
humanitarian aid shipments
as a cover
after a devastating earthquake in Syria
in February.
The sources say Iran
hid weapons and military equipment
among humanitarian supplies
that were transported by
convoys through Iraq.